Hello, I’m Sam, this is my channel, this
is that Wikipedia list, and this… is That
Wikipedia List.
September 3rd, 1967: Sweden decides to switch
from left to right.
Swedish motorists, accustomed to left-side-of-the-road
driving join the growing trend throughout
Europe to cross over to right-side traffic
flow.
That was a crazy day for Sweden.
Prior to 1967, Sweden, much like many other
European countries, drove on the left.
Most countries in the world in fact began
driving on the left because that’s how carriages
did it and carriages did it that way because
that’s how horses did it.
The rule started in the first place because
back in ye-olde-days most would brandish their
sword on their right side so when riding they
wanted to be able to respond to an oncoming
attacker on the right side.
Archeological evidence proves that left-side
riding was norm throughout much of the ancient
world.
The shift to right-side riding came when freight
wagons got larger.
As trade became more common demand grew so
teamsters—the old term for wagon drivers—started
adding more and more horses to pull heavier
and heavier loads.
There weren’t seats on these wagons so the
teamsters just sat on a horse.
Most chose to sit on the back-left horse so
they could whip with their right-hand since
the vast majority of people—especially at
the time—were right-hand dominant.
Therefore, the teamsters chose to ride on
the right side of the road so that oncoming
wagons could pass on their left and they could
clearly see that their wheels were clear.
Fast forward 200 years and 65% of the world’s
population drives on the right side of the
road, which, as it turns out, is the worse
side to drive on.
You see humans are naturally right-side dominant.
As we know, the vast majority of the worlds
population is right-handed—about 90%—but
the vast majority of the world is also right-eye
dominant.
Humans actually do have an eye that works
better than the other.
For about 70% of the worlds population thats
the right eye.
When driving on the left, the right eye will
focus on oncoming traffic while the left will
see what’s passing by.
This may contribute to the slightly lower
accident rate in left-side driving countries.
Anyways, let’s get back to Dagen H—the
name for the day Sweden switched.
In 1955 Sweden held a referendum on the issue
of driving directionality and a staggering
83% voted against changing the direction.
The national legislature known as the Riksdag
promptly responded by deciding to make the
change.
The rational was that every single one of
Sweden’s neighbors drove on the right and
most imported cars—which were the cheapest
cars—were designed to be driven on the right.
In the months leading up to Dagen H every
intersection was outfitted with an extra set
of signals and signs wrapped in black plastic.
8,000 busses were retrofitted with new doors
on the right side and the rest were sold to
Pakistan and Kenya.
New lines were painted on the roads then covered
in black tape.
Milk cartons and underwear with the day’s
logo were sold in stores around the country.
Contests were held for songs about the change,
then finally, on September 3rd, 1967 at 3pm
the law switched, and the entire country had
one enormous traffic jam as drivers slowly
inched across the white line to get to the
new normal.
No one died that day on Swedish roads… in
fact, nobody died the day after as well.
On the Monday after Dagen H there were only
125 collisions compared to the average of
164.
It seemed that the switch worked.
However, by 1969 collision rates were back
to normal.
It turned out that the roads were only safer
because drivers were more cautious as they
learned the new traffic patterns.
I’ll end with an only somewhat related but
interesting tidbit.
The Geneva Conventions have a treaty that
outlines international rules of the road including
the rule that traffic directionality must
be uniform throughout the same country.
The vast majority of countries follow this
rule with no problem, however, the good ol’
US of A holds the territory of the US Virgin
Islands where all drivers drive on the left,
and therefore the US is technically in violation
of the Geneva Conventions which, as the no-longer-existent
country of Yugoslavia knows, is kinda a big
deal.
Anyways, I hope you enjoyed this video.
Make sure to subscribe to catch more episodes
of That Wikipedia List and other videos I
make.
You can also follow me on twitter @WendoverPro.
Additionally, you can check out my last video
on the secret symbol that stops you from copying
money here or watch an old video of mine on
space law here.
Lastly, I think it’s worth mentioning that
I’ve been putting out videos far less frequently
recently.
I work seasonally in outdoor recreation and
summer is a really big time for that so I
just don’t have as much video-making time.
Once mid-August rolls along I’ll be back
to releasing videos almost every week.